hello my name is Florian Merkel I am a
principal investigator at the University
of Cambridge today I'll be talking about
disease modeling with human pluripotent
stem cells and I'll talk about my
personal interest which is disease
modeling of obesity and via that
framework I'll talk about general
principles of disease modeling and some
of the pitfalls that can occur when
culturing stem cells and when performing
gene editing so as a general principle
one can model human diseases in vitro by
the case-control method where one could
for example take a series of control
patients and patients affected with a
particular disease derive induced
pluripotent stem cells from them and
differentiate them into a cell type of
interest that's affected in disease for
example neurons if you're studying
neurological diseases and then if you
want is measuring a phenotype that's
associated with disease
since these are unrelated patients with
diverse genetic backgrounds there can be
considerable variability that is due to
not just the disease phenotype that's
being measured but also those different
genetic backgrounds this can be overcome
with the advent of of gene editing
technology such as CRISPR cas9 where one
can either introduce a disease variant
of interest or corrected in a patient
line to generate these isogenic pairs
which removes the effect of genetic
background and allows the contribution
of that disease variant to the cellular
phenotype to be more accurately measured
but there's still the issue of what data
type are you measuring in which cell
population so if one is differentiating
in vitro heterogeneous cell population
one might first want to generate a
knockin reporter cell line to allow one
to prospectively identify that gene of
interest and then on the background of
that reporter cell line one can
introduce that disease-causing mutation
and then either purify the cell
population of interest or observe it and
measure a phenotype this allows one to
more confidently attribute the phenotype
that's being measured in the cell type
if interest to the disease variant
so as I mentioned my interest is obesity
and genetic studies have very clearly
shown that the diseases that I'm sorry
the the genetic variants that are
associated with obesity are highly
enriched in the brain and indeed obesity
is really thought of as a disease of the
brain and there are particular regions
of the brain that play a central role in
regulating appetite and energy
expenditure and one of those brain
regions is the hypothalamus and within
the hypothalamus there's a few cell
populations for example the probl
melanocortin or pom c neurons that are
shown here in green that release a
neuropeptide known as melanocytes
stimulating hormone or MSH and this
peptide plays a potent role in
regulating appetite because it binds the
receptor on downstream neurons that
regulate food intake and energy
expenditure and the activity of these
pom c neurons is in turn regulated by
nutrients and hormones such as the
hormone leptin which is produced by fat
cells and studies in in humans and in
mice have shown that deficiency in
leptin or the leptin receptor is
sufficient to cause the severe early
onset childhood obesity and since this
is leptin deficiencies due to a
deficiency of a hormone replacement of
that hormone can effectively cure the
obesity so this individual as a young
child was treated for four years with
leptin which completely normalized his
weight but of course more common forms
of human obesity aren't due to the
defect of a particular gene and we'd
really like to understand how do cells
such as these pom C or programmable
opium Ilana court neurons since hormones
like leptin and how are they defective
in in in obesity so this has been
studied extensively in mice but there
are important species specific
differences between mice and humans so
it would be advantageous to be able to
model this in vitro so to this end my
laboratory as well as some others have
UPS protocols for differentiating human
pluripotent stem cells down to the nur
ectodermal lineage towards the forebrain
and then specifically patterning those
for brain progenitors into the
hypothalamus and then those hypothalamic
progenitors can be encouraged to give
rise to hypothalamic neurons such as pom
C neurons and so if we take these
cultures and stain them for neuro
peptides that are either exclusively
expressed in the hypothalamus or are
highly enriched in the hypothalamus we
see variety of different nerve peptides
including pom C which you'll see up in
the upper left hand corner and indeed in
our culture systems we see robust
induction of pom C neurons so in a
single 10 centimeter dish we see about
as many pom C neurons as you get in 5000
Mouse brains
so this has of course many advantages
because we can do experiments at a scale
that just wouldn't be possible it
wouldn't be very very feasible to do in
mice but of course the ability to model
diseases is contingent upon how good of
a model are these cells really so as I'm
showing in this high magnification
confocal image of one of our stem cell
derived pom C neurons if we stain for
alpha MSH which is derived from pom C we
see that it has this very punctate
vesicular like staining pattern so this
is consistent with what you'd expect for
a neuropeptide that's packaged into
dense core vesicles for release and to
take a closer look at the at the
regulation of pom C and pom c processing
and whether it's really processed into
bioactive MSH we used mass spectrometry
so there's a few different levels at
which pom C can be regulated it can be
regulated at the levels of transcription
and translation at the levels of
processing and of course at the level of
release where it would be then available
to act on the Milano court and for
receptor on downstream neurons so pom C
is kind of famous for being this
extensively post translationally
modified modified protein
and I've shown here a number of the
different peptides that are derived from
Pompey and I've highlighted in green
those that are thought to play a
prominent role in the regulation of
appetite and energy expenditure so in
the middle we see does a CTL alpha MSH
and which is a precursor of the mature
acetylated form of alpha MSH also
further to the right we see beta MSH
which is not produced in the rodent
brain but the sequences present in human
brain so it is thought that it might
play a role in human energy homeostasis
then finally all the way to the right we
have beta endorphin which plays a role
in nociception but also in promoting
feeding behavior so what we did is to
take our human stem cell derived
hypothalamic neurons lyse them and look
by quantitative mass spectrometry for
the production of these different neuro
peptides in what we found was that
desafio alpha MSH was produced at easily
detectable quantities and somewhat
surprisingly and encouragingly we also
saw that there was roughly equal molar
production of beta MSH this is important
because the existence of beta MSH in
humans has been controversial these data
really can have definitively show that
this is a real peptide that is produced
by human cells we also saw that beta
endorphin was produced at even higher
levels but the real surprise is that
alpha MSH which is thought to in from
based on studies in mice to play the
predominant role in regulating food
intake was produced at very low levels
so to confirm that this wasn't just some
artifact of our culture system we took
advantage of the fact that we have a
local brain bank where we can get fresh
samples of primary human brain tissue we
perform the same quantitative mass
spectrometry we found essentially
exactly the same result
where the Sussudio alpha MSH and beta
MSH were produced at very similar
quantities and at much higher quantities
than the mature alpha MSH
so this suggests that not only does beta
MSH likely play a prominent role in
human energy homeostasis
that we need to rethink and of the
central role that's been that's been
ascribed to two alpha MSH
since we have access now to these live
human hypothalamic neurons which of
course we don't from post-mortem
material we can ask does the production
of these neuro peptides is it altered in
response to hormones such as leptin so
what we did was we incubated our
cultures with the hormone leptin and we
found that indeed there is a robust
induction of both of both alpha MSH and
beta MSH and beta endorphin in response
to leptin so this really establishes
this culture system as a powerful tool
to study human metabolic sensing so just
to conclude this aspect of the talk I've
shown that human hypothalamic neurons
are efficiently produced in vitro that
pom c neurons generate these appetite
regulating paps peptides that have an
identical sequence and a similar
abundance to their counterparts in in
the primary human brain tissue and
finally that these cells actively
respond to the hormone leptin but the
question that remains is which cell
lines should be used for disease
modeling and that takes me into the
second part of the talk which is how can
we use genetic information to decide
which cell lines should we invest the
time and energy into to develop these
disease models and previous studies have
shown that the difference of genetic
background can be important and also
that over time and culture human
pluripotent stem cell lines can acquire
epigenetic aberrations such as the
erosion of X chromosome inactivation and
also large structural variants such as
copy number variants and aneuploidy
which can affect hundreds or thousands
of genes however relatively little was
known about what about smaller
structural variants or sequence variants
which can have a potent effect on on on
cellular phenotypes that are perhaps
unrelated to the disease that one is
wishing to study so this is
the work that I'm going to show was done
as part of a much larger team I'm
showing some of the important members of
this team postdoc Diego Shu I worked
with closely and Kevin again and Steve
maccarrol at at Harvard and the Broad
Institute as well as Nissen Ben vanessi
at the Hebrew University of Jerusalem so
what we did was to was to acquire 114
commonly used research grade human
embryonic stem cell lines drawing
heavily upon the list of stem cell lines
that are on the NIH registry of lines
approved for for use with federal funds
as well as 29 cell pellets from lines
that had been prepared for potential
clinical use under good manufacturing
practice or GMP conditions we then
analyze these 143 cell lines by a
combination of high-density DNA
microarrays whole exome sequencing and
whole genome sequencing and in
particular what we focused on was the
common sequence variants that give
information about the ancestry of the
cell lines whether they're directly
related to us and what their burden of
common polygenetic polygenic variants
are that predispose them to different
different traits or diseases we also
looked at rare sequence variants that
are associated with human disease as
well as structural variants such as the
such as large or small copy number
variants which can affect again tens to
hundreds of genes and potentially are
going to influence cellular phenotypes
and together by by analyzing down it
from the single nucleotide level to the
level of entire chromosomes we can
obtain this integrated view of human
genetic variation so first I'm going to
spend a little bit of time talking about
the work that we did on structural
variants so historically this has been
done by karyotyping and G banding or by
DNA microarrays but we wanted to ask can
whole genome sequence data give Richard
information about about these copy
number variants and indeed we found that
not only could we call many of the same
variants that we could by microarray but
we could also refine the boundaries so
here what I'm showing on a graph on the
y-axis is the normalized read depth of
the different lines what we see is that
the normalized read depth is around two
which you'd expect for for an autosome
but that some of these cell lines are
showing a deletion and that the borders
of this deletion can be more accurately
called
by whole genome sequencing just since we
have many more variants which whose copy
number we can analyze then we would buy
microarray which will have just a series
of probes that are distributed within
and without of the borders of the C and
V and if we look at this quantitatively
and just consider copy number variants
that are large meaning that there are
500 kilobase pairs or larger we find
that most of the most of the CNVs that
we've called by whole genome sequencing
we also called by mike by microarray so
that accounts for about 60% of them but
that there's another 40% so another 23
variants among the 121 cell lines that
we analyzed that were not detected by
microarray but could we're only seen by
whole genome sequencing but here we're
only looking at the very large variants
we can actually go down much lower down
to just a little bit over 1 KB and this
gives us it allows us to look at
thousands of additional copy number
variants by whole genome sequencing that
we could not detect it all by microarray
next I'm going to tell you a little bit
about the work that we've done to look
at single nucleotide variants and in
particular we're interested in those
single nucleotide variants that were
likely acquired in culture and the way
that we identified those was to look at
rare heterozygous variants which would
be expected to be distributed at 50/50
fraction of alleles of the reference and
the alternate allele but what we noticed
when we grasped
is that there was a small tail on this
distribution and this left hand tail
correspond to two sites where the
alternate or likely mutated allele was
present at an unexpectedly low fraction
and this would be consistent with it
having been acquired in culture and
present only in a sub population of the
cells and when we looked at all of the
genes that had these candidate mosaic
variants there's only a single one that
was affected more than once and that
turned out to be the tumor suppressor
p53 or T p53 and if we look at the
codons that were affected in insult
lines carrying these T V p53 mutations
they mapped perfectly onto those codons
that were most frequently seen in human
cancer so what I'm showing in the top
graph the y-axis here is the frequency
at which these codons are mutated in the
general population as represented in the
exact database and in the lower graph
I'm showing the percentage of all human
tumors that carry a mutation that that
causes a change in that particular codon
and I've highlighted the mutations in
the codons that we found in red what you
see is that this massively perfectly on
to on to the mutations that are most
commonly found in human cancer and the
reason that they're so commonly found in
human cancer is that the amino acids
encoded by these codons play a critical
role in the association of p53 with DNA
when in fact they act as dominant
negative when you have these mutations
so in the heterozygous state it this
leads to a dramatic loss in p53 activity
another nice thing about the fact that
these these variants happen to be mosaic
meaning that they're only found in a
subset of cells in the culture is that
it allowed us to do these natural
competition experiments to ask does do
these mutations actually confer some
growth advantage on these cells in other
words so really this is already a
perfect isogenic comparison
we're comparing exactly the same cell
lines and just the subset of them are
going to carry the mutation and if we
just continue culturing these cells what
we see is that the mutant cells which
are shown in red here over time and
culture which is shown on the x-axis
gradually out-compete the wild-type
cells and reach a state of fixation so
we found these mutations in cell lines
that we had acquired but we really
wondered is is this true also of other
cell lines that are out there in general
circulation and since more and more
sequencing data is being published and
since p53 is a gene that's expressed in
stem cells we could mine published RNA
sequencing data and look for evidence of
other p53 mutations so we did this
together with missing benvenuti and and
and a very talented graduate student of
his ish I of ER and when each I did this
work he found an additional a large
number of additional mutations in p53 so
that together we found 15 distinct
instances in the 252 cell lines that we
found so this is telling us that p53 is
likely playing an important role in
regulating survival or proliferation in
human pluripotent stem cells such that
loss of p53 gives a significant growth
advantage to these cells the other real
advantage of looking at the RNA
sequencing data is that certain cell
lines are very widely used for example
the h9 or wa0 9 cell line is used by
many different groups and this allowed
us to detect four distinct mutations in
four different groups that had likely
independently arisen so this is telling
us that clearly this is this is a
mutation that can occur spontaneously
and then can arise to a level of that's
detectable by either RNA sequencing or
whole exome or whole genome sequencing
because it confers this growth advantage
so I've talked a lot about these p53
mutations but what about other germline
variants that might be relevant for
disease so we have done a little bit of
work to to try to identify some of those
variants and if we looked at just those
variants that are present in the clinvar
database and are associated with
autosomal dominant disease we see that
there are genes that affect multiple
different cellular pathways and body
systems so for example we see mutations
in the better in eyes and the nervous
system in the endocrine system in the
cardiovascular system and many of these
and many of the cell types that are
important for these body systems such as
cardiomyocytes in the cardiovascular
system are frequently generated from
human protein stem cells and are used to
model disease or look at disease
toxicity and so it's important to know
that there are some some cell lines that
are out there in general circulation
that happen to have mutations that have
been associated with for example long QT
syndrome and so what we really want this
data to to allow us to do is to first of
all serve as a resource for the field so
we're planning to publish both the raw
data and the analyze data and also to
provide an interactive data portal for
groups to easily look across different
cell lines for mutations in a gene of
interest or to look at a particular cell
line and get an idea of what are all of
the different mutations that might be
present within that particular cell line
we also by by analyzing these data have
been able to generate new insights into
human embryonic stem cell biology both
by looking at these germline variants
but also looking at recurrently mutated
genes and pathways which include other
members of the p53 pathway and other
oncogenes and together these data
hopefully will allow us to generate
guidelines to enable other groups to
rationally select human embryonic stem
cell
for research or clinical use so to
summarize what I've told you in the
second part of the talk I've discussed
how human pluripotent stem cells
including ES and IPS cells
recurrently acquire mutations in p53
that they do carry disease associated
germline mutations just as the general
human population also has and that these
data will be provided as a resource to
the field to enable the rational
selection of cell lines and so the
takeaway message that I want to leave
you with is that understanding the
genetic background of human pluripotent
stem cells is really important to
consider if you want to choose the right
cell line to use and also to properly
interpret the results of your disease
modeling experiments so next I want to
show you the most important slide of all
and that's the acknowledgment slide
because obviously any of this work is a
team effort and I'm really indebted to
the people who have helped me along the
way the wonderful members of the Merkel
lab my collaborators and in particular
I've highlighted here in in in in bold
font Diego Shu is the postdoc who had
played a real leadership role in the
bioinformatics of all of the work that
I've that I've told you about in the
second half of the talk and the funders
both past and present that have enabled
this work to be done so finally I just
want to thank you very much for your
attention I've put my email address and
my twitter handle on there if you do
have any questions please don't hesitate
to reach out thank you very much